the latest attack on girls in school
this one came on Wednesday at an
elementary school in a Tehran
neighborhood young girls receiving
medical care after the latest suspected
use of poisoned gas in the classroom
[Music]
I can't breathe she says less than 24
hours earlier in a suburb just east of
Tehran similar scenes
these girls were also poisoned while
sitting at their desks
at least 35 of them were rushed to
hospital with symptoms including severe
headaches nausea vomiting and dizziness
I smelled something like gas all the
students did too but I felt it more
because I have asthma when I came back
to the classroom I couldn't tolerate the
smell and when I left I fell down the
stairs I smelled something like gas and
as we left the classroom I felt really
sick I was coughing and couldn't breathe
in the holy city of Rome multiple
attacks have taken place hundreds of
girls were hospitalized do you lose find
that she was paralyzed from the waist
down and she couldn't walk at all where
were those officials to come and see
that my daughter can even walk
parents are angry at what many see as a
targeted attack on girls education and
they blame local officials for not doing
enough to protect their children
the first cases emerge in late November
where students at the Noor yazdansha
Conservatory fell ill they became ill
again in December
we have not identified the cause of the
incident so far the issues being
followed by the relevant bodies and
hopefully we will find details soon and
share it with the public we should
refrain from creating fear
the head of the education Committee in
Parliament has confirmed that nitrogen
gas was detected in the poison used at
some of the schools
a committee made up of different
authorities has been formed to
investigate and the president has also
asked the interior Ministry to get
involved as confusion lack of clarity on
these increasing attacks continue
parents are becoming angrier and more
fearful for the future of their
daughters in Iran
Tehran